foreign
everybody Welcome to Houston Texas for
game one of the American League
Championship Series the Boston Red Sox
and the Houston Astros going head to
head on the mound for the Astros in game
one is from Valdez Valdez no decision in
his Division Series start game two
against the White Sox here gave up four
runs and four into third innings in that
ball game [ __ ] Hernandez as he gets
another base hit the long time Dodger
and a guy who started his pro career in
the Astros organization could not be a
better table setter right now here's
Kyle schwarber ground ball right side
Altuve they got one they've got them
both that's two score it four six three
double play two out dangerous hitter two
for one that sucks two outs and a runner
at first now
Devers pops it up that ball might drop
in it is a base hit and as it gets away
from bregman going first to third is
Bogarts and it's a single on a
well-placed little pop-up off the bat of
Devers that loads the bases they've got
four base winners in this inning not a
run to show Ford yet and it brings up
Hunter and throw six for 20. and that's
lifted out in the left Center shallow
Alvarez to his left McCormick to his
right McCormick the call and the catch
and the inning is over Chris Sale gets
it to make the start here Chris lasted
one inning and his first start at Tampa
against Tampa Bay but Red Sox came back
to win that ball game he is one and two
of course needs to play with it 727 era
and now it's bregman's turn with one out
and one on that's a base hit
a walk a line drive out now a single by
bregman and Bighorn Don Alvarez is
coming to the plate that gets away
Runners Advanced to second and third
that almost hit yard on another fastball
at 98 inside 3-2
got a Fly ball into left Altuve will tag
Verdugo comes up throwing and too late
Astros strike first just using his hands
that's it he knew he just had to put it
in play for Altuve Astros get the early
lead the Red Sox have their fifth base
runner so one on and no one out for
Christian Arroyo 3-2 is chopped to short
Correa Steph Fire Two Out second
straight inning getting a twin killing
for Farmer Valdez two out but instead
you get that two Hopper right over the
second base bag and Korea you don't want
to hit it to him here's a 3-2 to Vasquez
swinging and a man struck him out on the
curveball and the inning is over first
strikeout for fromber so Yuli is a board
with one out for Chaz McCormick and
McCormick lifts this in the left that
gets down for a base hit so not winning
a round balls kick For a Moment by the
left fielder Verdugo and curiel Dives
back safely to Second and the Astros
have loaded the bases for Altuve and
still just one out and the bases are
jacked
a strikeout and a big out for sale
I'll say wow what a good pitch right
there where's his first strikeout comes
in a most opportune time but not out of
the woods yet it's the very discipline
Michael Brantley in the air to Center
late Break by Hernandez and he's got it
two in the inning he saved at least two
runs [ __ ] Hernandez and a tumbling catch
in left Center failed to get Sail Out of
the jam the center fielder [ __ ]
Hernandez made that great catch and
he'll leave things off here in the third
here's one into left Center this ball is
up and out
yeah
way out TK ties the game with an
absolute moonshot to left center field
[ __ ] is doing it all he saves a couple
of runs in the second and leads off the
third with a game tying home run that
was a
448 foot home run so now 2-1 with only
one out for JD
and this one's boxed by Altuve digging
around third as Bogarts in the Red Sox
are on top
from what could have been an inning
ending double play ball to a ball that
just ate up Altuve and Bogarts around to
score and the Red Sox lead for the first
time tonight now Renfro who weekly fly
down to Center his first time with the
bases loaded ground ball Fair pass third
down the left field line one run will
score that steppers digging to third
Martinez throw to second two late and
it's 3-1 Boston here in the third it's
an RBI double
3-1 Red Sox so a two-run lead but two in
scoring position here's a 1-2 a swing
and a miss and that's out number two
Dusty Baker now out of the Dugout that's
going to be it for Valdez and Jimmy
Garcia comes in now for the Astros two
outs Runners on second third here's the
2-2 got him strike three strands two men
in scoring position Here We Go Again
tying runs the board with only the one
out and here comes Kyle Tucker swinging
a messy struck him out fastball up and
out of the zone and they're two down I
will say this for Chris Sale who's going
to come out of the game he didn't have
his best stuff tonight but when it was
all on the line he did hunker down and
make big pitches guriel's the batter
with Runners on first and second Boston
leads three to one adavino with a lot of
Sliders swinging a chopper to the right
side racing in on it is a royal he
stumbled he gloves he throws the first
in time inning over nice recovery by
Arroyo here is the man of the hour the
man of the week the man of the playoffs
[ __ ] Hernandez as this one is hit in the
air into left long run Alvarez can't get
there cool when you're hot
turns into a double
wow and [ __ ] is now 13 for 26 in this
postseason he got to Second and did like
a little check mark like all right I got
the single I got the Homer now I have
the double Xander Bogarts two walks in a
run scored Snyder got him strike three
two strikeouts for Javier in the inning
with the runner on second Josh Taylor
left-hander the third pitcher for Boston
facing Michael Brantley to start
into left center field this ball is down
Bradley will hold with a lead-off single
on base for the first time tonight and
he's now hitting 16 consecutive
postseason game tied for the fourth
longest in major league history Bradley
held on by schwarber 3-2
[Applause]
shallow Center Hernandez coming on
throw behind the runner and safe hearted
they avoid a collision there [ __ ] made a
backhand catcher Royal one out too far I
think it was playing very deep so first
and second for Tucker there's a drive
hit the right center field toward the
Gap kicking on the goal going back and
he makes the catchy almost over ran and
what a play Kiki went hard to his glove
side at the edge of the warning track
out by the bullpen and then had to reach
back and now it's [ __ ] Hernandez don't
have to pitch to him here with two outs
and a runner at third lacking just the
triple for the cycle swinging in a mess
Gallup on a high fastball and the Astros
finally retired [ __ ] Hernandez McCormick
back to first base now it's up to Altuve
he's the tying run two down in the sixth
Damage Done Thai game
end of the Landry's Crawford box we're
tied at three 20 postseason home runs
now for Altuve tied for third all time
with Derek Jeter altuve's second home
run of the postseason this year and he's
had a hand and all three Astros runs and
there's two way here in the seventh
that'll bring up Carlos Correa two for
three hard Fly ball to left this ball is
up and out
Astros on top
it's his time wow what a blast Carlos
Correa his 18th career postseason Homer
what a year what a run it's been for
Korea with the Houston Astros so the
bases are loaded Astros leading by a run
nobody out in the bottom of the eighth
and now two-way at the plate he has a
two-run home run into center field
Hernandez the catch tagging coming to
the plate the runner and throw too late
guriel scores 5-3 Astros the president
would face the top of the order Kiki
Hernandez Carl schwarber and Xander
Bogarts 26 for 28 and save chances for
Presley this season [ __ ] is single
homered doubled and struck out there's
one in the left it's a one-run game
another tape measure shot by [ __ ]
Hernandez and it's 5-4 here in the ninth
well he brought the tying run to the
plate he's did it in a different way
he's 12th in his postseason career and
he's just on Fire Red Sox down to their
final out and this game is going to come
down now to Presley and Devers
ground ball up the middle
Correa game over escrows win game one
5-4 Astros go up one game to none
winning game one of the American League
Championship Series
Michelob Ultra organic Seltzer as real
as it tastes